you
all right good morning everyone
it is uh 1003 we will
open up the work session here in
in ena
i want to welcome everybody back and
hopefully you all survived the weekend
so we have a few bills on our agenda
today that we're going to work on and i
intend to do
an exec session
not prior to 11 p.m we'll start whenever
we're done the work session but not
prior to 11 pm because i made that
commitment to a few folks who
were out so if we do get done our work
session a little bit earlier we'll just
take a break until after 11 but we will
be exacting anytime after 11 pm 11am
so we have
five bills on our scheduled work session
today i guess we'll take them in the
order that they were listed which
appears to be numerical since nobody
seemed to have a preference on
how we uh
how we did it
so the first one we'll look at is uh
house bill
1168 this is established as a study
committee
the new hampshire law relative to soil
conditioners and that is representative
bixby's bill
so
i'll turn it over to representative
bixby to discuss if there's any changes
okay so i don't see any changes
necessary for this bill i think that
we should pass it as is it's pretty
straightforward and i think this is
something that really does need to get
studied
uh and i'd be happy to take any
questions if people have
so i will uh
i'll open it up to the committee is
there any questions for representative
bixby or thoughts and discussion that we
i represented all me just grab a seat
all right i see no questions from the
committee
thank you good morning
representative bixby have a question
about is there anywhere that defines
what a soil conditioner is
uh that is actually one of the things
that belongs in the study because uh the
bill the current statute does not
define what a soil conditioner is even
though that is the title of the
chapter in state law
any further questions or discussion
so i'll remind members of the audience
we are in a work session and while we
don't specifically have a in a
way to take public testimony if you have
some thoughts that you'd like to present
to the committee i will certainly
entertain it just to raise your hand and
i'll try and call on you as soon as i
see you or throw a pen at me or
something if you don't get my attention
but we'll uh we want to make you also
involved in this if you have some good
input that you feel the committee needs
obviously i'm not going to be looking
for long speeches but if you've got a
you know a question or a point you want
to raise please feel free to do so you
okay 11 68 then uh
appears we're good with that as a
committee and everybody seems to be in
support of ought to pass as recommended
by representative bixby so
we'll move on to
house bill 1547 which is setting the
maximum contaminant levels for pfcs in
the soil
we we did get
a good amendment that was brought to the
committee by uh representative
maureen mooney when she introduced it
last week
for the life of me i can't lay my
fingers on it right this second
thankfully my vice chair has it
so i'm going to open it up to the
committee
i know the the amendment
significantly changed what the original
content of the bill was in my opinion in
a very positive manner
so i'd like to open it up and have some
discussion from members of the committee
or questions obviously the prime sponsor
isn't here but we can
we can talk about it amongst ourselves
so
anybody i'd like to open
representative bixby yeah i'd like to
say that i had
looking at the original bill i had some
significant questions and
looking at the amendment i thought that
all of my questions and more had been
very effectively addressed and i i think
that the
amendment that was presented during the
any further discussion yeah
representative duttsy no i just want to
be uh clear because i'm going
by one list and it's not on there are we
talking about 15 47 yes you know what i
looked at the wrong list i grabbed the
hearing list instead of today's one i'll
get back on schedule okay so it's 15 47
i have two agendas in front of
contaminant levels
that's what we're on yes okay yes and i
agree with everything that uh
representative bixby said
uh i thought the amendment was excellent
okay
now we'll get back on the right agenda
house bill 1186 relative to companion
animals during a declared state of
emergency now there was an amendment
that we just passed out that um
the sponsor rep gallagher emailed in and
sent
to the committee just a short bit ago so
many of you may not have had an
opportunity to take a look at it did
okay and that is amendment o three two
two h
reptusia there are extra copies of that
there perhaps put them up on the table
if anybody in the audience would like to
i'm going to give you just a minute to
read through that and
and then we'll
everybody had a chance to read through
that
any thoughts or comments from anyone on
the committee uh representative comptoin
um yeah
um just looking at line 10 i think
there's a word missing where it says uh
animal kept an enclosure that might
typically be found in a home not just
typically found in home but
um i don't know if that's an important
word and i will refer to representative
bixby
representative bixby
uh that i think representative
commonwealth i correctly identified a
grammatical issue there that should be
fixed before this goes forward but
i actually have a content issue as well
uh one of the
um
one thing that was brought up in
testimony last week was that
community shelters often don't have the
capacity to sufficiently separate
animals
and
that could cause a problem
with that part of the
uh of the bill so i think that
i i think including the
uh response volunteers under the
insurance
uh for emergency workers does make sense
um but uh i i think that that it does
not do the entire fix the bill needs i
i think that the intent of the bill is
uh
is good and i'd like to um make a in
amend it in such a way that we can uh
make it operational but i don't think
we're there yet and i don't think that
um
i think it's going to take a little bit
more study than what we have the
thank you representative aaron
thank you mr chair yeah i i would i
would wonder
uh representative bixby if you think
that that line the maximum number of
animals per family entering the hotel or
community shelter shall comply with
local ordinances
and she and we can add in and shelby as
space
is available or is required
you think something like that white
might
help that thought
uh it might but i'm not um
i'd also like to our committee
researcher um
gave us a a
sheaf of research on this over email and
i'd like to also take a look at that in
context with this i didn't have a chance
to print it out and i don't know if the
um if it's
available for us
i don't but i i'm not sure that i think
this is a bill that we were already
thinking would come to another work
session later
uh and we're not executing it today so
um i think that's just roughing out the
territory that's important is i think
the key thing rather than trying to come
up with an exact language fix right now
yes i don't know if everybody on the
committee saw that we
did get an email from um
from dan mr tory our
researcher and there was some
information that was provided should
have come to you i think last evening or
late afternoon but
representative mola
thank you chair um i
i understand the intent of this bill and
as a pet owner i'd be heartbroken if i
had to choose between my family's safety
and our pet being left behind
but i do have a fundamental issue with
requiring places that are used as
shelters such as even hotels i mean the
fact remains that some places just are
not
they're not suited for pets and and
given the the range of pets also
um you know this doesn't address any
kind of
any kind of pets that may have more
aggressive tendencies things that might
not mix well with others
again
i'm i'm grateful that places like hotels
will open up their door when there's
need but but we can't let it be a
liability for them that might cause
potential potential damage to their
facility
and i just don't think it's fair to
require it of them
um i i think it's great if they wanted
to offer that if they could be flexible
but but it's not i think on us to
representative murray um thank you mr
chair for taking my comment or yeah it's
not really a question um
am i so in in looking at the policy here
that was sent to us through the
committee researcher it looks like there
are about 48 pet shelters across the
state that have some sort of
policy for taking in companion animals
at this point
so i was curious to know if this in
addition to
what representative
hamlet had mentioned
if it would be something that an
individual
establishment might take a position on
and invite
folks to
bring an animal but that would be their
own
purview to do so i don't
um i'm trying to
see
it also
looked
like it did recognize that
every effort
to kind of keep animals near in
proximity to their owners would be made
but it couldn't guarantee that
necessarily they could be housed in the
dutsy did you have a question earlier
i'm sorry i think i skipped over you
yeah
um there's uh well there's a couple of
things first of all i thought in the
public hearing
that there were some concerns about the
term community shelter
and whether or not
that
should be further defined
and i think it was agreed by everybody
that you know if we were looking at a
community shelter such as a high school
or whatever it wouldn't be appropriate
to have a number of animals
together in that shelter because you
know just it would be one large room and
it would cause a lot of problems so i
think
you know that that really needs a lot of
attention there
and the only other thing i was going to
say
is that in the
rsa that was referenced i had referenced
it when i made a note
and after
um
roman numeral six
i had a small c
okay so i don't know if that would make
a difference in terms of what actually
was referenced in in that but that was
left off of this amendment also so
any work should kind of check that out
so there's one concern that i had
because within this language we are
mandating that these shelters take
once we do that as a legislature we may
be putting a financial burden on the
local community to say well you know
what my shelter isn't good enough the
shelter that we have do we have to
upgrade our shelter facilities because
we are now going to have to accommodate
companion animals along with their
owners
i just that that's a concern that i
thought when i read it i don't know if
it's valid but i certainly could see
that it
might make a community re-look at its
facilities and think well if i'm going
to have to accept companion animals then
the shelter we have isn't suitable for
that so just just a thought that i had
as well
rep murray
um
would it
benefit to say that
any hotel or community shelter
may
how's i mean is that
representative yeah um i'm not sure that
that would change anything that already
exists
uh see because um
i i think at this point hotels do have
the option of
of providing for pets if they so choose
so
rep tutsi
but again you know this bill is in
reference to
a declared state of emergency so i mean
if we look at a declared state of
emergency like you know hurricane sandy
or hurricane katrina
i mean it could be i mean it's a mess i
mean there's
you know i mean you know we have a
statute that says
uh pet owners should make arrangements
with a local shelter uh for their pets
during an emergency but the fact of the
matter is you know a lot of we don't
know it's an emergency until it's
already happened
and if the roads are flooded
uh you know people aren't going and we
have no telephone service we're not
going to be making arrangements and so i
think when we talk again going back to
community shelters
in an emergency a community shelter
could be any large public building
so i think you know i think we really
need to take this look at this seriously
in terms of the context
of a declared emergency because that's
different than just what's going on on a
daily basis
rep compta
thank you mr chair um i'm just sitting
here listening and um
we're talking about a declared state of
emergency and um
if not all of us but most of us have
pets that we consider part of our family
um
however
something just occurred to me
is that we don't know if these pets that
we would be putting into a community
situation with people
if they're up to date on their shots if
they have any
diseases
that could be transmitted and
and to require businesses and things
like that um
what you know
i so i agree with representative bixby
the intent of this bill is extreme
has been extremely well thought out but
i really think that we need to
study uh some of the other aspects that
can happen during a state of emergency
especially with animals and especially
representative vonsky
thank you i'm curious if
if this could potentially set up a
situation where
a shelter such as like a gymnasium or
something which is one large open space
would be put in a position where
okay we've we've filled up but 20
percent of that room is animals and then
we have humans knocking on the door
saying hey we want to get in
we need shelter but there's not room
because
my two dogs donkey and artemis are in
there or whatever and i'm not again i
agree with the point of the bill i just
i would hate for the person running a
shelter to have to choose between or be
put in a position where the law says
okay we have to take these pets
but we also kind of want to have room
for humans as well so
i don't know exactly
where i was going with that but i think
that's
i think we're all sort of sharing that
same concern as how do we find that
balance of again where
the bill language is mandating that
these shelters take them you know it's
you shall do it
and i
well again i agree with all of you i
understand the intent
i think it may create a problem when
we're already in a situation of a state
of emergency where things could
get a little hectic rep dutsy
yeah i would suggest uh is this
something that could go to a
subcommittee um so that the the
one the language of it could be looked
at and also maybe a little bit it sounds
like a little bit more research
needs to be done and i haven't been able
to
you know read in depth what uh mr torrey
wrote here but
just looking at it it looks like this is
fairly general and it i mean it would be
very interesting to see maybe what the
state i mean has the state of louisiana
put any of these
laws into effect after katrina or
new jersey after sandy and maybe you
know if we had some law that we could
look at we might be able to do better
job of it so i would recommend a
it is not an early bill it's not due out
until march 10th so we do have a little
time we can work on it so certainly take
that under advisor
representative
if i could just add to that thank you
sir
i mean i think that what we're talking
about is do do we or do we not require
hotels to take pets you know in the gist
of it and i'm not sure any amount of
studying is going to change that
question
it's either we are going to put this
burden on hotels and shelters or we're
not
so i just wanted to to add that on there
i do think it would be valuable
information for the committee to
understand how perhaps other states have
done this you know we certainly can
use that input not that we necessarily
always follow that but it's always good
guidance to see if there's a good idea
any other thoughts and comments on
oh yes
yes um so i think that um
we actually probably have a fair amount
of leeway in terms of how we could amend
amend this and uh in the research that
there were
one of the things that was mentioned was
what policies are in place for making
sure that pets are reunited with their
owners after they've been in a shelter
during an emergency and it sounds like
there's a range of that from
uh good luck to uh there
you need to actually have a system for
um making sure people are reunited with
their pets
and
um
so we could
uh that's something we might want to
look into in in the course of studying
to see if
we can
make sure that there is a uh that i
think massachusetts
uh requires that pets be in a
separate shelter that is relatively
close to
the
where their families are sheltered
uh and has some some mechanisms in place
for making sure that they're reunited
uh it sounds like there were a couple of
states where it was like okay well
uh if
the owner doesn't come and claim their
animal after a certain amount of time it
gets put down
so
i think we probably want to be closer to
massachusetts than putting down people's
pets because they can't find them
but i think that's that's the business
that's what would
be proper to do in a study or you know
uh representative murray
yes also um one of the things that i
think i remember in the testimony that i
would like to see
um
maybe touched upon
additionally is the comment around um
when we talked about the definition of
shelters i think there were these
emergency trailers too that were being
used and so my question is do those
constitute as a shelter if so is that
included in the definition for the bill
and if you know if that shelter is on
site at a hotel parking lot for example
does that satisfy that requirement or
representative dutsy
yeah
just for clarification i was looking at
mr torrey's uh i think
and it says here on page four
none of the state laws regulations or
plans as of this
as of the writing of this memo
require all hotels and community
shelters statewide to shelter pets with
their owners
state
that they require hotels so that i think
all right i'm going to uh look through
our
subcommittee
availability and i'll certainly take a
take that under consideration and
when i get a chance to look through that
list then i think we'll make a decision
where this should go
anything further before we move on to
the next bill anybody in the audience
all right
okay
we will move on to house bill 1226
so we received a lot of
testimony on this bill that was a rather
i guess i'll throw it out to the
committee and kind of see where
where everybody is if there's any
thoughts on work that needs to be done
everybody's
oh representative bixby yeah
excuse me
so
i
i think the the practice of
uh declining cats is basically a bad
practice
uh and
we
on the other hand we didn't hear
um
we didn't hear much testimony saying
to what extent this is an issue in new
hampshire
so
uh that it kind of puts me on the fence
with this bill
one of the things i really don't like
about this bill is that it criminalizes
the veterinarian who performs it
i think that that aspect of it would be
unacceptable
i could imagine having some sort of
statement in law saying that this
practice is discouraged
uh so it might need amendment but uh
i don't i uh i certainly could not pass
the bill as is uh but i would consider
uh an amendment on it
representative dutsy
um yes uh
i uh i strongly support this bill
because
cats scratch
dogs bark
and kids run
and that's just the way life is and if
you can't accept that then maybe you
shouldn't have a dog a cat or a child
but i understand what
representative bixby is saying and i
went back and looked at our 2020 bill
which was hb
1387 which was almost identical to the
bill that we've been presented
except for the fact that it said any
person licensed or certified under this
chapter who removes the clause of a cat
in violation of paragraph one
shall be punishable by a fine to be
determined by the board of veterinary
medicine
not to exceed five hundred dollars
and i think that would would be
appropriate because then you could have
the veterinary board and i know that
there is
some concerns about that board but still
you could have a veterinary board
look at it and make a determination
and you know there there may be at no
fine whatsoever because it because it
addressed the concerns that one
veterinarian
had at the public meeting was what
happens if
an animal comes in with a tumor i have
to remove the tumor but then i also
realize that i have to remove
other digits
on the on the paw
because of
you know
a more invasive process so i think
that this
if we added this amendment to it
that it would protect the veterinarians
but this law would also give them a tool
as a response to use for some aggressive
clients of theirs who they do not want
to offend
but it gives them the you know the added
backing that by law they can't do this
for cosmetic reasons only
okay and and that's really what we're
talking about
is that this bill
you know um bans declawing
um for the convenience of the owner
and again cats scratch dogs bark and
kids run
and so i i see that this is a very
reasonable bill
perez
yeah um i just want to say that um
the the way the bill is right now
i cannot support it especially when it
talks about criminal penalties um
i
been trying to see any other state that
they have criminal penalties for these
kind of
problems but i haven't find anything
that i can really see it clear
for that reason not
the way that the devil is right now that
i
thank you rep mason
yeah
thank you mr chair over the weekend i
spent some time with
small animal veterinarian friends of
mine and and i ran this past them
and the ones i spoke to said they don't
remember the last time that they
declawed a cat in recent years other
than for a medical reason so i think
we're chasing something
that has
issues today at new hampshire
and
as i heard in testimony there's only one
state that has a law against this
so i think from my own perspective well
i certainly
respect all the things that the points
that have been brought why
it should be in favor of
declawing i
think i tend to agree that
the testimony seemed to be pretty strong
from my perspective that there wasn't
this isn't really a big new hampshire
problem and that
i always struggle with getting into
into the
realm of dealing with veterinary patient
interaction and while i
certainly would be respectful
representative dutzy to your position
that this would give the vets a tool to
say no i think they already have the
tools to say no from my opinion if they
choose to is it's not a good idea and i
won't perform that practice for you i
don't recommend it i think that
that option is already available for a
veterinary to to say to their client and
i think that's very much part of the
care and the responsibility that
veterinarians take when they take their
oath that they're going to give their
clients the you know the best guidance
as far as the care and health for their
pets
i think at that point if any
most any veterinary i know anyway would
if the
client kept pushing it they would
decline and ask them to find another
veterinary to perform that practice
because they didn't feel it was in the
best interest of the animal so from my
perspective having a lot of years in
animal
husbandry that's uh i've certainly had
conversations in detail with with my
veterinary over the animals that you
know were sick or needed some care and
i always respected the opinion of my
veterinary so
that would be my thought anybody else my
way in rep aaron
thank you
thank you mr chair i i happened to speak
with my own veterinarian this week as i
took my cats in for their annual checkup
and i asked her the question about it
and she said that
she can't even remember the last time
she did any kind of declaw in her
practice and that in her practice
she only knows of one cat that's
declawed as a you know one of her
patients
so i again i'd have to
echo what you've just said in so far as
i don't really think that this is a new
hampshire issue or that it is an issue i
don't think veterinarians for the most
rep control uh mason i'd ask you shut
your mic off
thank you
thank you mr chair
um
you know this is the third time i've
heard this bill
and
every time every year we have asked what
the number of
animals
on a yearly basis are being declawed in
new hampshire and we get the national
figure of 20-25 percent
but as we sit here and i listen to folks
who've talked to the veterinarians and
it is the practice of them to discourage
they do not like to perform this
procedure unless it is medically
necessary and they actually discourage
it from my understanding and talking
with my vet um
for any other reason
and i think we heard from some other
veterinarians
and all of us here could probably go and
speak to our veterinarians and ask how
many do d-clause do you do a year and i
don't think you're going to get the 20
25 to 25 percent figure that we've been
uh that's been touted uh over the last
any further thoughts or comments from
the committee reptusi
i'll ask the committee what's the
downside of passing this bill
if it's amended to take out
criminal
anybody else want to feel do you want me
to
well from my perspective again i won't
speak for the committee
my perspective is it's we're putting
another law on the books that isn't
really solving something that's a
problem in new hampshire i think our
veterinaries that do a really good job
in deciding what is appropriate care for
the animals for their clients animals
and i i just don't see that this is a
problem that rises to the level of
requiring more legislation i think that
this is
a practice that is already done with
with care and and thought in by the
members of our veterinary community in
new hampshire and i just don't think
that we need to regulate them on that
decision i think it's they're doing a
very good and conscientious job on their
own
rep dutsy
last comment
i have a constituent who will only have
declawed cats
because she
feels that her vintage furniture
would be destroyed so she's obviously
getting these declawed cats from some
place
so i
i just wonder about i mean i know it's
not as prevalent as it used to be
but i believe it's still out there
any further comments from the members of
the committee representative perez
yeah i don't still
i don't see these bills necessary for
our state because
to be honest like we could continue
someone else has said already 25 25
nationally but in new hampshire i don't
see that necessary for us to put another
any further comments
representative von plinsky
uh thank you thank you mr i don't just
necessarily disagree with you and
i i do wonder just from a
abstract point of view at what point
does something
how many times does something have to
happen before
it rises to the level of legislation um
again i'm not saying that you're wrong
on this one or that any of us i just
that that question keeps coming up when
we when when that reason is used
no no and that's probably a different
level for everybody you know to make
that decision but uh i'm you know i sort
of i gave you my opinion and
representative comptoa
thank you mr chair
um
so in seeing this bill come back year
aft you know year after year
and listening to the folks that
testified
it seemed that this was a problem
many years ago it was common practice
but as veterinarians have learned and
their their concern is for the health of
their the animal
um and i believe that most veterinarians
um
there's a reason that a lot of
veterinarians do not practice or declaw
because they see that
it may not be in the best interest of
the animal
but to put this into law and even have a
small penalty
might
put into question a veterinarian who
might be performing a medical procedure
and say well if i have to remove this
tumor and may have to remove another
digit
but it's questionable
you know
where are they going to draw the line
and i think that we need to let the
veterinarians practice the best medicine
any further thoughts and comments from
the committee
i think we've had a
pretty good discussion on this bill as a
committee and i certainly appreciate all
i guess i'm not getting the feeling that
a
further work session on this bill would
really solve
the divisions in
in the opinions of the members of the
committee so i
i'm feeling that we'll put this bill
when we go into exact section we'll
bring it forward and we'll see how that
goes from there everybody okay with it
okay
okay then we'll uh we will move on to uh
house bill 1454
relative to the permits for the sighting
of new landfills
we do have an amendment
is that
here that
representative tucker sent for us
and i do see that representative tucker
is here would you like to come and speak
turn the mic on please
i take it this is uh you would like to
have this very brief yeah we're gonna
would it's not my intent to do a lot of
work on this bill today we will schedule
another work session next week on it as
i had said to you in our phone
conversation but i'd certainly like to
look at your amendment and give you an
opportunity to present your thoughts to
the committee and have a little
committee feedback good
uh i have the copies from ols i haven't
been through this process before
and
so i gather someone on the committee
needs to amend
accept this amendment well if it would
have to be someone on the committee that
would move it in when when we do execute
the bill i wasn't sure that you were
going to be in attendance from our
my
colleague
dr finkel who is the scientist who has
worked on this and i had a
really very
substantial and cordial conversation
with director wimsat
from des
and after that
and after rereading his letter that he
brought in testimony here
all of his concerns were answered
by the amendments that we incorporated
into the main bill section c
which talked about the future
is eliminated entirely
and there are small changes made in the
first two paragraphs
making it clear that nobody needs to go
on to anybody's private
property
to do anything
the the applicant is not put in that
position so those are the major changes
which respond to his concerns
and we are very happy with the fact that
we were able to do that
and
of course with the cooperation of
the drafting attorney
so that's why we are presenting it
next week if you have a work session i
think
we can have more information
i would love to get feedback from you
either by email or
in person today
as to
other concerns that you might have
about this bill but i think that this
slimmer trimmer
less complex bill is a very very good
one and i'm happy we were able to make
those changes
well i'd like to thank you for uh
listening to the testimony from and
questions from the committee members and
i appreciate your effort on that
so i know some of you may not have had
an opportunity to really digest the
content of the new amendment but we'll
uh we'll go around today and get what
questions and concerns that people have
and perhaps we'll
be able to do a more thorough job next
week we have so many bills on the agenda
this week i knew it would be different
so do you have a do you have a day next
week i do not i have to check with the
committee assistant and make sure i'm
pretty sure tuesday will work but i need
to before i commit to that i just need
to confirm that it's available
but i will do that representative bixby
yes um so i
look through this amendment and on the
whole i really like the way it works uh
there are a couple of specific questions
i have
one is um and do you know if shallow and
deep groundwater are terms that are
defined elsewhere in statute
i don't know that we'll find out
so if they are not then i would say that
the other thing i is just a
um
just a sort of a clarity of writing
thing on the last sentence it's a little
bit
cumbersome and
i could suggest i could uh
uh uh or five times x
would be a a more
succinct way of saying that and i i can
i can work on the language and send it
to you as
that seems very doable
i think we've tried to have something
that
the applicant can understand
people on local
conservation committees can understand
and so i really appreciate
any
drive to clarity
okay and one one other minor uh
thing there is that uh
the phrase as is currently the setback
specified in rules
uh doesn't actually
work that phrase doesn't make sense in
statute because you're if you're
referring to current rules
stat
statutes are sort of a higher level than
rules
so you can't you can't really reference
rules and statutes unless unless you're
saying there's rule making authority
good
representative kampla
thank you madam chair
um
so in reading this bill i noticed that
then on line six it says
landfill disposal area is proposed to be
located sufficiently close
i think that's very ambiguous
and sufficiently close could mean a lot
of things to different
people
i think that needs to be defined a
little bit i'm not sure
exactly what that means as far as uh
location
well
i i
will certainly take a look at it but you
have to take it in
along with
would be able to reach the water body
within five years
and maybe we can make it a little
closer uh
thank you um
representative murray
uh thank you madam chair for taking my
question i so just to be clear we're
talking about the amendment rep contract
is that correct on line six
okay sorry thank you
yes
okay so
um
representative yeah so i think that uh
red in you know if you read it
grammatically
uh sort of looking at the whole context
that's sufficiently close
can be
kind of makes sense but the fact that
uh in
in reading it it raises questions i
think there's probably a way to rephrase
that that will make it clearer
i have a question mr chair
i'll get you back
thank you
thank you for bringing this amendment um
so given some of the questions regarding
needing definitions
did you in your conversations with the
es
discuss any of that
as needing being defined
was that no that they didn't yeah
we spent i'd say close to an hour
talking with the director on a three-way
phone conversation i'd never used that
format before and
i've
moved away from thinking zoom is the
best and thinking three-way phone is
pretty good too
but he did not mention any need for
definitions but
since the purpose of such a law is to
make it
understandable to a large number of
people
if if that's what people think is needed
we'll certainly see if there is one that
yes go ahead is it your intent then in
the um
effort to clarify some of those
definitions to go back to des and talk
to them about their thoughts on that i
certainly will i i saw that
but
i don't see him okay thank you
he's actually right behind you if you
look over your right shoulder
you are here
but with a mask
uh representative compta
uh thank you mr chair um just i'm
reading this again
um and i'm not a geologist so
bear with me because i don't understand
everything but um
i believe that our groundwater in our
streams underneath the earth change over
time
and so from a geological standpoint
due to geological changes underground
water can take to start taking a
different path how will we address that
issue
i think just the way the law does now if
that happens it happens but
it's rare
go ahead follow it
thank you mr chair so based on this if
right now the path is for
you're going to base something on five
years out but all of a sudden there's a
geological change and the path
reverses course and then goes somewhere
where it wasn't intended to go
maybe there needs to be a phrase that
says just how that would
how that would work
all right any further thoughts or
comments for rep tucker uh
representative bixby yeah i think in in
terms of you know if there is a change
of the course of a river or something it
pretty much that's that's not something
that we have
control over
and if that happens after the permit is
granted then i think the permit is
granted
uh and if it happens
before the permitting process before the
granting of the permit then that would
need to be taken in account into the
primating process because this law is
based
this piece of statute that you're
proposing is
specifically
establishing the setback necessary for a
okay director rimsett would you have any
interest in having a few words on this
or is there nothing further you'd like
okay
thank you rep tucker i think we'll uh
in the interest of time i'm going to uh
we're going to have a full
worked uh
yeah
work session on this next tuesday i did
confirm the date is available
um we'll convene at 10 a.m we may have
more than one bill to do in fact i think
we'll have two but we
will plan on convening the committee at
10 a.m on the on the 8th of february and
we'll work on this bill as potentially
another one so director rim said if
you'd like to come up and we'll have a
little discussion
see if the committee has any questions
for you representative bolden did you
have a question for the director yes
thank you mr chairman and thank you
director wimsat for taking my question
um we just talked about uh groundwater
kind of changing is that something that
usually happens relatively quickly or
does that happen over hundreds or
thousands of years
uh i think in the context of what we're
talking about um you know i think we
talked a little bit about this during
the hearing i think i fielded a question
on it uh really that the kind of thing
that would the kind of changes that
would impact this kind of analysis
are things i think i mentioned like a
river evulsion which is very rare in
here i mean at least
rivers move over time but they tend to
do so rather slowly and when they do so
very rapidly and violently it's called
an avulsion
i'm not an expert on this i'm aware of
one of those things happening in new
hampshire within the last 20 years and
that was the suncook river but it's yes
so i would say it's relatively rare to
have that kind of a change okay thank
you
representative bixby yes um so i had a
concern about the definition of uh
shallow and deep groundwater and i was
wondering if those definitions exist in
statute or if that's something that
you could
help in the drafting of an amendment to
get definitions for those
i'm not aware that they exist in statute
certainly not in 149m
and it's almost always helpful to have
clear definitions in a statute so that's
something that could be evaluated i
think
in the context of what this bill is
seeking to accomplish
um there may be maybe another way to go
at it just to say you know
to evaluate it
you know in the in the groundwater
environment both deep and shallow if you
start trying to
if you start trying to really carefully
define it you almost maybe box out what
you're trying to do i think the way i
would read this if this bill were to
pass that the agency would be directed
to um you know that the consultant that
would be hired by the applicant would
need to look at the whole
um
plausible groundwater flow regime
beneath the landfill and determine where
the maximum seepage velocity might occur
okay follow up
yeah so if you could uh help us with
some language to make that a little bit
clearer so that
uh so that
someone who was
doing the hydrology for a permit would
you have a
pretty um clear
clearly laid out uh assignment for how
that's assessed sure it's not
immediately clear to me how to
accomplish that but i'm happy to work
thank you mr chairman
uh director wins said on i'm on my
conservation commission
and i
uh about 10 years ago went to a
national new hampshire association of
conservation commission's
uh
annual meeting and there was the
hydro
the fluvio geologist of the state
was presenting a really vivid number of
slides showing how far
rivers have moved
over the last 70 years
in new hampshire particularly the ones
in the north country were the ones that
they were showing
and
i wonder do do
when you're dealing with the landfill
issues now do you consult with the hydro
with fluvial i think he's a fluvial
hydro geologist
uh yeah i think you're referring to dr
sheen chicky who
actually he has since become the new
hampshire state geologist
but
i'm not sure that we've had direct
consults with them on
applications that we've reviewed before
but that's certainly something to be
available to us
thank you i i don't know if that ought
to be involved in
in the bill i haven't had a chance to
look at the bill i'm just subbing thank
you
thank you any further questions for the
director
all right thank you sir we appreciate
any uh any more discussion from the
committee before we move along we are
going to have a much more thorough work
session on this next week and i think
we've given um
representative tucker some at least some
good good start yes i'll come ahead
please
so i will
send out to all the committee my
email that i use on a regular basis so
that if you do have questions that arise
as you look at this again
please send them on to me i'd like to
come fully prepared next tuesday thank
well thank you for your willingness to
consider the committee's concerns
anything else before we move along
okay
our last bill on the work session agenda
is uh establishing the capital
improvement grant program for the
benefit of state fairs and agricultural
so i understand from uh that
representative bixby had some concerns
and i guess i will
open the floor up and let him express
those and that's we'll kind of start
from there
right so
um
one of the things that
that
comes up so when when i look at a bill
that is
uh
saying we're going to be
uh creating a fund that annually is
drawing 250 thousand dollars from the
uh
from the general fund one of my
questions is where might that money be
otherwise used so is this a policy that
is
of a greater
uh good than other policies that um may
be competing for that 250 000
a couple of um
specific examples come up that i can
think of are
um we had a we actually have a retained
bill that is looking at creating
a
uh actually it's a
interim study bill looking that's
looking at
uh creating a
grant of
um
as written it was a grant
the idea is perhaps to make it into a
revolving loan fund that would provide
matching funds for
farmers who are trying to get federal
uh
value-added produce grants uh and
or production grants and
i'm wondering okay so in order to fund
that fully
it was initially funded
the suggestion was 100 000 and it was
decided it was
someone who testified indicated that was
probably insufficient
so i'm wondering okay so
would 250 000 dollars be better used for
something that helps our
uh
farmers get
uh loans from the more loans from the
federal government so that they can
produce do more value-added production
or is it better for affairs
uh another uh issue that came up uh
was a bill that initially that i think
originated in a study committee that
started in this committee
was um whether there should be
regulation on cbd
so that uh we so that it's clear that if
you're buying cbd somewhere in new
hampshire what you're getting is what is
labeled on the bottle which is still not
the case
and that
stalled in the senate uh because coming
up with 340 000
on a one-time basis was
uh
what was considered perhaps too much
even though it would have eventually
been entirely funded through fee income
so i'm thinking okay so
we're saying 250 000
for
uh doing capital projects at fares
versus these other things which may in
fact be
more important for the welfare of our
state so
i i'm really hesitant to say yes this is
uh this is just
we can pass this just as a policy matter
because we kind of like fairs
while
we're also making a policy judgment that
fares are better than some other things
that are
not uh as you know that maybe
should be considered higher uh priority
than the fares
so that's that's my concern
thank you representative so i i think
the the bill you were referring to was
um
house bill 627 that was that's the one
we still have an interim study
so i i guess i would just quickly
respond by saying that the committee
hasn't decided that that's not a good
policy we just wanted the opportunity to
look at it a bit further
and we don't have the opportunity with
the second year bill to have interim
study in the same manner
so um
we can look at it
but um
again right i understand and i respect
what you're saying right so i'm not
suggesting that there was some sort of
you know
zero-sum game here that with that
specific bill but if we look at a broad
range of bills and we think about okay
so what are what are the priorities that
we are
uh emphasizing
right so i just wanted to you know as i
talked to uh the members of my caucus
this morning when we discuss this bill i
just
we kind of need to look at it as a
policy consideration the money side of
it it's going to a second committee we
kind of have to let finance do their job
and i just want to remind the committee
our job is the policy policy decision of
do we think it's a good idea to support
the state fairs with so making a grant
program available so
i saw hands uh representative murray
uh thank you mr chair for taking my
question this question is actually for
welcome
good morning hi so thank you for taking
my question the question that i do have
is i'm curious to know
um
what portion of these buildings may or
may not be considered historical in
nature and does that affect at all the
to the well to the best of my knowledge
you know i i think
to be historically probably have to be
on the state register or the national
register i don't recall seeing any of
those
those plaques there
you know and i can
only speak
for my for myself not what the next
commissioner may
may feel but i think
that
if it's a building
that is supporting agriculture
uh i wouldn't look at it versus as
what's the historical nature of it what
is the the physical need to make make
sure that whatever that building is
that it stays in a usable
condition
um so obviously in any building the
first priority is really going to be be
the roof and probably the second is
going to be the foundation
or maybe reverse but
i guess if you don't have a good roof it
really doesn't matter what condition the
foundation is in but um
so
but um you know they're they're both
important but um i think making making
sure that the building is usable is
going to be
uh the priority that anybody would look
at
representative dutsy
yes uh thank you chair and thank you for
taking my question who owns the building
who owns the buildings now and who owns
the land
so to the best of my my knowledge the
fair association
owns
the land
lands and the buildings
there may be cases where there
is a different
maintenance
arrangement because i know there are
cases where different organizations have
put up
buildings that they use exclusively but
i think ultimately
uh the buildings are probably owned by
the fair association but i i really
can't
speak to that
thank you with any certainty
thank you mr chair
in speaking about this bill and i
understand uh with regards to competing
funds and as you know i had an idea of
where the money should come from and
definitely not from the general fund
but the other thing that we heard in
testimony and discussion is that these
fares are viable to our economy
they bring in a lot of dollars
to
our local businesses
and they promote agriculture in a way to
keep it alive
i mean
we are an agricultural state in many
ways
and
when i think of new hampshire i think of
our rural communities our agriculture
our our farms
uh over four
i forget i think it's over four thousand
farms in the state um registered
so
i think keeping a lot and preserving our
history as an agricultural community
and promoting these county fairs is an
economic interest not just purely
helping with the maintenance of these
buildings
but the economies that support these
fairs and the surrounding communities
it's
so it it brings in dollars to the state
it's not just an outflow it is it also
you have to look at the inflow from the
representative mason
well i'd just like to speak from my own
experience
my family did not have any agriculture
when we first started but my first date
with new hampshire affairs go back to
some photographs and memories that date
i can say this
i've had opportunity to work in
agricultural
in many parts of the world
i've worked as far away as new zealand
australia england
canada
and throughout the western united states
and eastern united states in agriculture
and one of the things that we really see
is just a demise in the family farm
there's very few left
that
the commissioner could speak on how many
family farms are left in new hampshire i
know representative pearl knows there's
very few we've watched a lot of friends
that have had to fold up take second
seats and that but the one thing the new
hampshire fairs do and they do a very
good job of it they educate young people
to want to have a life in agriculture
now i didn't come from that
but yet
two one of my brothers and myself both
have spent a career in agriculture
and if we don't support things like new
hampshire fair programs and the youth
programs in new hampshire
it's far different than a festival of
people having fun it's a lifestyle and
it promotes agriculture and this
committee is
committee of agriculture
so
i guess i'm in favor of it
any further questions for the
commissioner
bixby yeah i was just wondering um
is the are the fair associations a um
are they public bodies or are they
well
they are
to the best of my knowledge
registered non-non-profit
so that
you know they're like any other
non-profit people
can can join the associations there they
have elections to um
for their officers
et cetera so
i'm not sure if that answers your
question but i'm not sure i understand
it a hundred percent either okay so i
can clarify so i'm wondering if they are
under the jurisdiction of
the state or of a county or of uh
municipality or with are they
uh
private nonprofits
well i think they're they're probably
private non-profits
in the sense
that your local historical society would
be your lions club your your kiwanis the
grange any of those there is
certainly uh state oversight in terms of
how they operate and how they deal with
their money and
there are federal
thank you
any further thoughts uh representative
do you know how
fares are run in other states for for
example i grew up in michigan
i remember going to the michigan state
fair
the state fairgrounds was the state
fairgrounds
but again i don't know if we had
regional fares like they they do here
so what uh what do they do in other
states and my and my question is is are
we looking at the wrong bill
and should we be looking at um
maybe bringing
agricultural fares under the auspices of
the government similar to what we have
like with parks with our state parks
because it is
so ingrained in our culture
well i would certainly not recommend
that
i'm not sure what other
states do i know that some of them have
much more
involvement but i've never looked at it
how they are
are set up what i meant was some
some departments of agriculture have
much more involvement in individual
state state fairs and some truly are
state fairs where we
don't have anything any fair designated
by the government
i think that for the most part um
we do a pretty good job but our fares
are are struggling and i think that
trying to bring
more uh government
involvement
at that level would probably end up
being a lot more expensive for us than
than this
uh level of of support
so um
yeah they're
it's it's a difficult situation and it
is different um
i think in in every state
um but i think we've got a pretty good
system but i think again
for the last roughly 40 years the state
has not been
supportive of our fares whereas
for the previous
40 years and even
going back
to the 1800s
the legislature
was supportive of our our affairs we are
in a period of time which i think is
pretty unusual
in that there is no
state support really
for
a longer period of time than has existed
before and i think we're seeing
the affairs suffering because of that if
we had sunny weekends all the time
and no other issues this probably
wouldn't be necessary but
like everything i said before we have
some
difficult
weather and it's it's showing in some of
these facilities
representative aaron thank you mr chair
do you know if any of the counties
support these fairs financially
i have never heard of that i think that
you know
you're probably all members of different
delegations and i wouldn't be surprised
if
all
10 counties were represented on your
committee
uh and i think you could best answer
those questions i know that hillsborough
county certainly has never put any money
into any of the fairs that exist within
representative
thank you thank you mr chair uh yeah as
being part of the executive
committee of hillsborough county i mean
the function of the county is really to
take care of the jail uh the nursing
homes and um i think what is a policing
like the the sheriff's department and i
can i can tell you our budgets
are scrutinized very very strongly we do
support uh
the
unh extension
so some of the money you know does does
go to
a portion of that for 4-h and that type
of thing
but
you know every
penny is scrutinized and we've had to do
we've had to spend a lot of money
on just retaining people
so giving a lot of retention bonuses uh
because the nursing home has been under
uh such strain
representative comptroll
thank you mr chair um basically
representative dutsy touched upon what i
was going to talk about
unh cooperative extension in our county
is very active as is 4-h and they are
involved in the belknap county
fair i don't know to what extent
but i know that 4-h
shows there
and i am sure that um they help out with
whatever they can
to make that a successful affair
so
may the county does not give out dollars
per se to the fair
but i think through
some of the organizations that we
support
financially
representative almighty
thank you commissioner
good on
i asked do you know anything about uh
on
whether
there is money left
in the arpa money
that
acquired
for this purpose
and if so
whether
it would help the fairs to have a
that really is something i
i don't know um
at this point there have not been any
arpa funds
that have been apportioned for
for agriculture and i think that um
what would be would be if one-time funds
and i think that it
a revolving fund is what is
is necessary here because these are not
going to be
expenses that
are
going to go away they're going to be
continuing infrastructure needs
representative bixby yeah i'm wondering
if there might be a
mechanism for funding that does not rely
on the general fund
there are a number of uh
sort of narrow purposes that we cover in
the state using some sort of a fee
rather than uh rather than a fund that
rather than drawing on the general fund
um and i'm wondering if there might be
some other avenue for
uh
for funding this as opposed to the uh
i i suppose anything is possible when
you spoke earlier about cbd i was
thinking well there's a clear case to me
where those who are buying the product
could have an assessment that would go
to support the activity of testing i
don't know of any way
really
to do that with with the fares um
because if they had the ability to raise
enough money
then they you know at each fair they
would probably be
be doing that now i don't you know to be
honest i don't see this as
something where every fare is going to
get an equal amount even based on
gate attendance
they're going to be a lot of factors
some fares could go probably a long time
without getting anything because of the
fact that they have
you know huge attendance
but in terms of
trying to assess
somebody else
some fee for this i don't really
see that as viable
you know and i hear about general fund
versus coming from some other source
you know i sort of view wherever money
comes from as being
you know one pocket and you can call it
one thing or another but at the end of
the day there's only a finite amount of
money available to the state for all
their
expenditures so if you say well we're
going to take this money from this fund
well that money was probably going to
the general fund anyhow and so now
you've just switched it switched it
around so i think it really is a matter
of is this
something
that the state should be supporting or
not that is the policy
the policy question
are there other funds available such as
the specialty block grants which
the
the federal government's already putting
a good amount of money into new
hampshire for that
we just
accepted i think another 189 thousand
that was an additional amount
over and above what is normally
appropriated by the feds for specialty
crop and that
goes to a
limited group of people for them to
promote their products essentially it's
it go those type of funds don't go to
the individual farmers they go to
like the fruit growers association to
promote the products of all of their
members
um whereas this is like
you know a situation where
we're just trying to keep the fairs from
follow it
uh another thought that occurs to me is
that
because this is essentially capital
maintenance would this be something that
would make more sense to put into the
to the best of my knowledge
capital budget goes for
state
state building state projects
um
how that
would work
potentially it could i'm not
saying that it shouldn't but that adds a
whole different layer
certainly would take a while
longer i mean i i suppose i suppose it
could i'm not sure what the different
ends up difference ends up being because
something that would be bonded so it
would just add to another layer which is
fine because i'm not looking for
another
uh job myself
but
um i don't know in the
in the grand scheme of things
looking at
you know
a whole bunch of little buildings spread
out all over the state
owned by
12 or 14 different organizations
that level of
commitment on the part of a already busy
group of people
where where that would wash out unless
there was a again a specific
amendment to that process that said you
you shall
appropriate
up to and that that's part of the
problem too i also see that they're
going to be years when
we're probably not going to award 250
000 knowing that there are some bigger
projects coming down the road so you'd
want to
you know say all right maybe this year
there's only critical needs of 150 000
knowing we've got to have money
available so for some bigger ones
uh in in years coming down down the road
much as most of us plan if we know we're
going to replace a roof on our house or
or something it's not going to be 250
000 every single year
so
i i'm having a hard time
short period of time trying to figure
the program for for capital improvements
for the entire state well i think
commissioner that's probably a better
question for the finance committee than
it is ena anyway so representative
murray
thank you for taking my question um
thank you also um to the commissioner so
you stated that there are roughly 12 to
14 buildings depending on
no no 12 12 i can't remember the number
of fares i should have counted it up
it's it's changed a little bit
um
but no fairs and they all have multiple
buildings 12 to 14 fares thank you um so
follow up
um so
in addition to that question i guess
then um
once the application you had mentioned
this previously a little bit that the
application would come to you with a
request for these repairs and and
um
is there a group of individuals that
would look at the application and decide
who gets awarded what let's say all 12
or 14 fairs apply that year or two apply
how was that grant awarding process i
didn't write the bill and i'm not
familiar if there's a process laid out
there or not it's within the department
of agriculture if it's left
solely to the discretion
of the commissioner i would probably
have a group of of people and we would
most likely
go out and do a physical site visit to
those fairs and look
at the buildings
to really evaluate them because even
even pictures aren't going to tell the
whole whole story
so my anticipation would be that when
fairs made applications we would do a
site visit
look at the actual condition of
of the roof the foundation whatever it
was they were were looking for i mean
this is the bill that representative
ladd came up with i did assist him with
it but this was not a department
so i'm just going to give you a quick
answer so um
in the we've given the bill would give
the commissioner
have him adopt bulls relative to the
administration of the
capital improvement grant program so
that's how that would be handled
yeah
that the bill does call for that
representative dutzy
uh
yes i mean if i if i'm looking at the
the financial statement i mean they're
talking
and they're just dividing it out 250 000
they're talking about 13 fares
so let's just say twenty thousand
dollars for fair sight
um that doesn't seem to me to be an
awful lot of money
and because these fares
are i would say regional in nature and
they're generating
economic development for those regions
and we have an economic development
person
i believe in each county
through the unh extension
and their job is to help small
communities um develop economically
why
or how involved are the towns
in funding
the maintenance of these buildings and
and if not why not since it's generating
economic development
well i i think
that's a question that i don't have the
answer to except to say that i am not
aware of any local community supporting
any of these these non-profits
that probably gets into a very slippery
slope and you could ask the same
question about why
wouldn't
the state of new hampshire then be
supporting the maintenance of
the kiwanis building or the lions hall
um and i think
that my answer to that is because that
those organizations
serve are there to serve their
communities they fundraise to provide
money for those those organizations and
and themselves in this case these
these and they are able to fundraise and
operate year round these these fares are
eliminated
are
operating three to maybe 14 days
a year and then they have to do other
things to try to support themselves and
i think it's the unique nature of
agriculture in the history that that the
state does have a history of supporting
our fares in the state of new hampshire
representative bolton
i'm sorry my question's been answered
thank you okay uh representative kennedy
thank you mine is um
referring back to policy and why we're
here we're here because we want to
reflect that this bill is good policy
and that is designed correctly to go to
finance which
in my personal opinion it is
over the past 20 years
showing at all these fairs
during the pharisees and off the fair
season i have seen the degrade
and value of a lot of the buildings
there's only so much fundraising and we
heard this all in the testimony that
happened
in front of us
last week and
you look at sandwich hopkinton new
boston hillsborough county fair
grafton they all have been doing that
local fundraising they've been working
their butt off i know a lot of the
people on those types of boards and this
is going to help them
be able to grow because in the off
season which you just mentioned
they've rent that out to 4-h those
4-hours are paying premium costs to be
able to rent out that facility to show
their animals so they can make it to
biggie so they can make it to all the
regional affairs
our job is to make sure that this is
good policy so it can go to finance so
it can get approved so we can let those
4-hrs continue to grow
i'm emotional because it's very close to
my heart but
thank you
and thank you representative kennedy and
if i may
to your point
new boston which was primarily a 4-h
fair
because of the economic situation
there their board of directors has moved
in a direction of looking strictly at
what's the income best income stream and
to a large degree 4-h is being pushed
out of those fairgrounds
during the year
because of the fact that they have to
make these these choices to maintain
what they have there
and hopefully this would help and these
would be the considerations
that
i would look at and i would anticipate
in putting into rules what are the
off-season usage for things like like
that and certainly that would be a
priority because these these
4-h need the opportunity to be able to
learn in the proper environment how to
show their animals and how to do the
things that they need to and if the
fairgrounds are saying well they're not
there because we're going to put boats
and
you know in
in other things in storage and the
buildings aren't going to be used that
that would need to be a factor because
the 4-h is is very very important and i
think you see in the bill that
you know
4-h and ffa are are important
requirements
to receive funding through this through
this build
representative mason
thank you
commissioner could you tell me uh
one question the
capital improvement would also include
items like bringing
power services up to grade
bringing up
septic systems up to grade a lot of new
regulatory issues that have come down
the line that
this legislature has passed is being
forced on
uh these fair associations to do a lot
of modifications
and improve your facility to try to
bring them up
to a quality standard that currently is
not acceptable i know back when we were
young it was a lot different than it is
today
but um i know that's put a lot of
pressure would that money be available
for those types of capital improvements
as well
my reading of the bill and how i would
intend to
put the rules in place would be that any
of the infrastructure needs related to
the agricultural
portions of the fair would be eligible
and i touched on that a little bit in
terms of fire regulations but obviously
you know septic and in electrical would
be part of that because ultimately if
you know the fire department or the town
comes in whoever is doing
that is going to come in and look and
say your your facilities are not
adequate we're going to shut the
building down that's got to be part of
it
follow up
follow up go ahead
so when we go to some of these fares we
see some that have very large gate
attendances like
dear field fair look at deerfield very
large gated attendance uh deerfield fair
produces a lot of money but we go to it
is belknap fair still active
it is it's just i think gone through an
uh an ownership
change
um it was owned i think by 4-h i don't
think
4-h owns it anymore now it's owned by
okay another organization but it's
primarily 4-h but as we come to some of
these small affairs they run under a
whole different
budget restriction and they just don't
have the funds available to do any of
these changes so
you would put together
a group within your system that would
within your um
office that would manage these funds so
those would be more available to the
organization they would have to put in
a an application for the funds with the
detail
of what it is there
they need and
how they're going to expend them and
then we would review those applications
i say i can't on any basis on an as
needed basis and so you know there will
be people that will be very unhappy i'm
sure
because at some point you're going to
say well look look how much money went
to belknap fare for instance this year
but it's going to be based on on those
needs where you know i i
love deerfield fair i go there every
year that's always been my favorite fare
i don't see that they would be getting
a proportional amount of of this money
because they are probably the healthiest
fare they have so many other activities
that they're bringing in money you know
with their horse arenas that those
things they're always able to bring in
other money where bell now probably
isn't but yet it's an important fair to
that region and i don't want to see any
any fairs
go under yet this this can't be a fund
that okay we're just gonna support
belknap every year after year after year
um there's there's a balance here but
they're probably early on this program
you're probably going to see some of the
the smaller fares get the lion's
share of the money early on to make sure
that they don't go under
thank you commissioner we appreciate
your time thank you i appreciate you
so this is an early bill we're going to
have to exec on it today representative
bixby i actually have a question for
representative compton
you mentioned that you had some other
idea for funding rather than general
fund could you explain
um
thank you representative so in when we
were discussing this bill
i was looking at why couldn't because
originally
this came from the um
the race track down in rockingham park
is how
uh this
uh these capital improvements were
funded uh or the state fairs were funded
and so
i was wondering why we couldn't take a
look at the historic horse racing which
is very similar to how
you know it's the same venue basically
of how these state fairs were funded
previously and why couldn't it be funded
that way um
but as i understand we are just a policy
committee and we would actually have to
leave the funding to
finance thank you
i think that would be a wise choice
since they have a lot more expertise and
knowledge in
that area than we do here
any uh further thoughts before we come
out of work session and go into exact
session
yes
secured yes uh so
we have to execute this today is that
what i understand because if it's
because it's an early bill
i'm going to run up against the deadline
i'd like to execute today i think i
could push it a few more days but i i'm
not sure that we'd
i do you have an idea that might change
some of the committee members minds
it's not this just be
my personal feelings i'm having a hard
time with this bill uh i like the idea
of supporting agriculture but there's
some other parts of it that i would like
to think through
i understand if we have to move it
forward that's fine but if we're going
to meet again next week anyway
and it's possible to push it to that
point then i would appreciate it but i
also understand if we have to go forward
today let me just check and make sure
mr chairman it's the 17th
yeah but the speaker gave us a date of
the 10th because he's moving it forward
so
we could push it till next week um the
so what i'm looking at is
here's my concern
hold on one second representative i'm
considering putting both of the
remaining bills we would have beyond
this into subcommittees
and so we wouldn't have the full
committee assembled next week and if i
push this off then i'm going to have to
require that the full committee come in
that that was all i was trying to be
respectful of everyone's time while we
were all here
and so the the two if we exact the
things that i had
planned on executing today we'd have two
bills remaining which i was going to put
into subcommittees
it was kind of my thought but i'm
certainly open if it's the will of the
committee to push this off and you all
want to come in next week i can do it by
deadline
representative perez
i feel the same way i'm having a hard
time with this bill so i
i have a lot of thoughts and i need to
like
if i gave you a 15-minute break would
you have an opportunity to think about
it because i do have to get a little bit
of paperwork before i go into exact
session
that's certainly fine here i
would happy time and a few to
get any clarification you need yeah to
be honest i
i get it but in the same way i'm very
concerned about
money is only going to a certain fair
more money is going to certain
areas in the state and not the others
and um
for that reason
my
my heart is divided which way to go so i
will remind you that this is a second
committee bill
you'll have an opportunity it's assuming
it passes here in the house floor you'd
have an opportunity to give further
testimony in finance where they might be
more able to address your concerns
properly about how the the allocation of
the funds would go more so than we as
the policy committee would be
okay i'm going to take about a 10-minute
break here because i've got a little bit
of paperwork i have to
retrieve before we go into exec sessions
so we'll um
we'll come back into exec session at 11
50.
it
you
okay we're going to open up the exec
session and we have quite a few bills to
go through here so we're going to
we will
start with house bill 1111 and i will
look to representative dutsy for an is
motion
representative bixby would you like to
sure
um so uh
i move uh interim study on uh
hb 1111 and representative control for a
second yes i a second uh interim study
on hb111
so we have a motion for interim study on
house bill 11-11
and the second do we have any discussion
from the committee yeah i'd just like to
make a comment on it so uh
the um the idea of extended producer
responsibility is uh
something that is um
has a lot of promise for diverting
uh
waste from our landfills uh but uh
we have included this bill the content
of this bill in
the 1049 which we
uh
the study committee that we passed
out of this that we recommended otp
uh otpa last week so uh
this is now redundant but we're just
gonna make an interim study to uh for
insurance
seeing none i'll call on the clerk call
the roll on interim study on house bill
11-11
representative aaron yes
represent comptrois yes representative
johnson
yes
representative lange
yes representative moffett aye yes
representative pamola yes representative
kennedy
yes representative mason yes
represent yes representative bixby yes
represent bolden
yes
representative dutzy
representative murray yes
representative von plinsky
representative all me
yes
represent perez
17-0 motion passes
all right we have a 17-0 vote on house
bill 11-11 for interim study and the
motion passes
i just realized i forgot my gavel so i'm
going to use my hand
are we okay with that going on consent
next we have house bill 1121
relative to solid waste sites now look
to representative murray for an interim
um given similar um circumstances where
i believe this bill is also we're just
looking for a motion sorry thank you mr
chair i'd like to make the motion of
interim study for bill hb
1121 thank you
so we have a motion and a second for
interim study on house bill 1121. and
i'll
turn over to uh representative murray
for her comments
thank you so again uh with respect to
hb1121
this is also included in the study
committee of um
and with that i have no other comments
thank you any further discussion from
the committee
seeing none
we have a motion for interim study on
house bill one one two one and i will
ask the clerk to call the role
representative aaron
yes representative contra yes
representative johnson
yes representative lang
yes represent moffat
yes represent pamola yes
representative kennedy yes
representative mason yes
representative sanborn yes represent
bixby yes
represent bolden yes
represent duty
represent murray
yes
representative von plinsky
representative
yes representative perez
yes mr chair yes
17-0
motion passes we have a 17-0 vote and
the motion for interim study passes
everybody any objection to putting in on
consent
okay and we'll go to house bill 1134
and i will look to representative bixby
for not to pass his amended motion
remind me what the which one this one is
they all blew together
do you have the amendment to 11 34.
oh disposal yeah okay correct
right so um
okay so
um
i move uh on to pass with uh amendment
on
uh on hb 1134
and i guess it needs a second and then i
can
move the amendment actually you have to
move the amendment first i'm sorry i got
that backwards
okay so
um
so uh i'd
move amendment uh
see um
2022-0228h
on uh hb 1134 and i'm looking to
i second that representative bixby would
you like to speak to your motion
yes so um
this bill came to us uh and it was um
there was a lot of strong testimony in
favor of making a study commission on
this
uh but this is an area that um we
actually don't know that much about on
our committee and we've arranged to
have this go to uh resources as a second
committee
so
we made a couple of amendments to just
clarify that this was more in their
bailiwick than ours
and that it be a committee rather than a
commission
uh so um
the uh the intent here is to make sure
that this does get studied because the
disposable wipes uh
do cause uh significant damage to
sewage systems and septic systems
and
it needs to be dealt with in some way
and resources will have a better way
better sense of how to deal with this
bill
thank you any further discussion from
the
committee seeing none i'll ask the clerk
2022-0228-h an amendment to house bill
1134.
representative aaron yes
represent
representative johnson yes
representative lange yes representative
moffett yes representative pamola yes
representative kennedy yes
representative mason yes representative
sanborn yes
representative bixby yes
represent bolden yes
represent
representative murray
yes represent von plinsky
representative
yes
represent perez
yes mr chair yes
17-0
okay we have a vote of 17-0 on amendment
0-2-2-8-h
so it passes now look to representative
bixby now for that ought to pass this
amended motion
i move uh
hb 1134
otpa with amendment
2022-0228-h
do i have a second from representative
aaron i second that
the
otp
about to pass as amended
has been moved and seconded on house
bill 1134 is any further discussion from
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
the role on house bill 1134 ought to
pass as amended with amendment 028
h
representative aaron yes representative
contoir yes representative johnson yes
representative lange
yes represent moffitt
yes represent pamola yes represent
kennedy yes represent mason yes
represent sanborn
represent bixby yes
represent bolden yes
represent dutchy
representative murray yes
represent von plinsky
represent army yes
represent perez
yes mr chair yes
17-0
so
the vote is 17-0 and house bill 1134
passes otpa as
and are we okay with that on consent
next we will take up house bill 1420 fn
prohibiting the issuance of new landfill
permits until the state solid waste plan
is updated i will look to
representative murray to introduce an
amendment
thank you i would like to
i'm just trying to figure out which one
i would like to move the amendment um
two zero two two zero two six seven h as
ought to
happen okay we have an amendment to our
area motion to uh
move
and then met o267h
do i have a second from representative
mason
yes
representative mason ii representative
murray would you like to speak to your
motion
if i i'm just trying to remember did
sure i'm sorry representative all right
so um
the uh so what the amendment does is uh
it makes a um
uh it clarifies that
the original bill said facility um in
line five
and the uh the this amendment changes
that to clarify that it's just landfills
and that it excludes the expansion of
existing landfills uh and then
the other change is that it um
sets up a
um
a contingency which uh
for the repeal and a contingency so
uh the repeal will be triggered by the
publication of the final publication of
the state of solid waste plan so this
doesn't remain on the books forever and
ever
any further discussion on amendment
02678 representative dutsy
uh yes can you just clarify uh i think
i'm looking at the wrong amendment i
have
uh 0.118h
and is this a
another amendment that came after that
uh the amendment we have presented is
0.267h
i'm not sure what amendment you have in
front of you
six
so there there is
not two amendments from the committee
there was an amendment that rep
massimilia had suggested that we look at
during the hearing but there was an
amendment drafted by representative
bixby and i that took into consideration
the changes that rep massimilia had
suggested as well okay and i did not
sorry for the confusion
any further discussion on the amendment
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
the role on the adoption of amendment
0267h to house bill 1420 fn
represents
yes
yes yes
okay we have a 17-0 vote on
amendment0267h
and i will look to representative murray
for an otp a motion
yes i'd like to make the motion of otp a
for house bill 1420 as amended
and then representative mason did you
want a second second
okay we have a motion to move house bill
14 20 fn as amended using amendment 0267
h representative murray would you like
to speak to your motion
no i think it speaks for itself anybody
else wish to comment
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
the role on house bill 1420 fn otpa with
representative aaron yes representative
contoir yes representative johnson yes
representative lang yes representative
moffat yes represent pamola yes
represent kennedy
yes
represent mason yes
represent sambon yes
representative bixby yes representative
bolden yes
representative dutsy
representative murray yes
representative von plinsky
representative almi yes
representative perez yes mr chair yes
17-0 okay the bill the vote is 17-0 so
house bill 1420 fn passes otpa
can that be put on the consent everybody
okay on consent
next we have house bill 1652 fn relative
to the recycling of beverage containers
and i will look to representative bixby
for an is motion
okay uh i move interim study on
uh what was the number again uh 1652. uh
hb 1652 and i will second represent
bixby would you like to speak to your
motion yes uh so this is another uh
actually this is uh
a bill where
there might be some uh
utility in uh some in some sort of a um
a bottle redemption plan as a way to
reduce flow to the landfills we saw some
evidence that it uh in states where it
is used they have a much higher
diversion of recyclables however
the bill that was proposed had enough
laws with it that it was not really
amendable in this uh in the time frame
for this year
and we also want to look at it in the
context of other mechanisms for
diverting
recyclables from landfills so
because this is not the bill for now but
it's it's an idea that
merits some study we'd like to do an
any further discussion from the
committee
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
the role on
house bill 1652 with the emotion of
interim study
representative aaron yes
representative contra yes representative
johnson yes representative lange yes
represent moffitt yes represent pamola
yes
representative kennedy yes represent
mason yes representative sam bowen yes
representative bixby yes
representative bolden yes
representative dutty
representative murray yes represent von
plinsky
representative almi yes represent perez
yes mr chair yes 17-0
house bill 1652
fn with a motion of interim study and a
vote of 17 to nothing passes
everybody okay on consent
hey we're doing good we're halfway
through
okay next we'll open up house bill 1168
as
establishes a
the executive here session on house bill
1168 it establishes committee to study
the new hampshire law relative to soil
conditioners and i will look to
representative bixby for a motion about
to pass
yes i move out to pass on hb 1168. and a
second from representative imola my
second motion we have a motion of otp on
house bill 1168 and i will about to pass
and i will recognize representative
bixby to speak to his motion uh just
just briefly um
this is a chapter of law that uh has not
been studied in a long time and there
are we noted some flaws in it uh having
when we visited it for
the purposes of other legislation recent
in the last
year or so
and
so this is something that
really needs some work and
this
combat study committee is the best way
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
the role on house bill 1168 with a
motion about to pass representative
aaron yes represent
yes representative johnson yes
representative blang yes represent
moffitt yes represent pamola yes
represent kennedy yes represent mason
yes represent
representative bixby yes representative
bolden yes representative dutsy yes
representative murray yes representative
polinski
representative almi yes representative
perez yes mr chair
okay we have a vote of 17-0 for ought to
pass on health spill 1168. any everybody
okay with on consent
next we'll open up house bill 1547
fn setting a maximum contaminant levels
for
perfluorochemicals in the soil and i
will look for an amendment from
representative aaron
thank you mr chair
yes i'd like to
move the amendment
thank you do we have a second from
okay we have a motion to
move
amendment 0249h on house bill 1547 and i
will represent that excuse me recognize
representative aaron to speak to her a
motion thank you
so this amendment was presented by
representative mooney and
the amendment
is going to replace the entire bill it
is in three parts the first part allows
the commissioner of des to initiate
rules for soil remediation standards of
perfluoro
chemicals by november 1 2023
and
this
date is a prime reason for this
amendment
because the united states geological
survey is performing a study in new
hampshire of its soil due by the fall of
2022 and this study is critical to
setting those soil standards the second
part of the amendment amends the
groundwater protection act rulemaking
section
to add soil that a person which it also
includes companies and public or private
corporations
is liable for such contamination
provides safe alternative water to an
impacted well owner the third part of
the amendment
which is section 3-7 clarifies language
describing
certification requirements for certain
hazardous waste generators to avoid
confusion and maintain consistency so
that's what this amendment is all about
and i hope you support it
thank you representative vinnie
so i just like to uh represent bixby i'm
sorry i'd just like to uh
second or um
agree with
what representative aaron said there
thank you representative bixby any
further comments from the committee
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call a
role on an
um
otp on amendment number
excuse me adoption of the amendment
number 02498
to house bill 1547 fn
representative aaron yes
represent country yes representative
johnson yes represent blang yes
representative moffat yes represent
pamula yes representative kennedy yes
represent mason yes represent sanborn
representative bixby yes represent
bolden yes represent dutsy yes
represent murray yes represent
vamplinsky
representative
yes represent perez yes mr chair yes
17-0
okay with the vote of 17-0 the committee
now i will look to representative aaron
for an otp otpa
motion on house bill 1547 with amendment
0249h
thank you mr chair yes i do
move on otpa on house bill 1547
with the amendment 0249h
and representative murray one a second
yes i'd like to second that please so we
have a motion in a second representative
aaron would you like to speak to your
motion
i think we've said what we need to say
thank you representative any further
discussion from the committee
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
to call the roll on an ought to pass as
amended motion for house bill 1547 with
representative aaron yes represent
contoir yes representative johnson yes
representative lang yes representative
moffatt yes represent pamola yes
representative kennedy
yes
representative mason yes represent sam
boyne
representative bixby yes represent
bolden yes
representative dutsy
represent murray yes representative von
plinsky
representative almi yes represent perez
yes mr chair yes 17-0 with a vote of
17-0 the ought to pass has amended
motion on house bill 1547
passes
we decided we could put this on consent
because the
fiscal note is zero dollars so everybody
okay with that
next we'll open house bill 1187 relative
to milt pasteurization and i will look
again to representative aaron for the
thank you mr chair
so i'd like to present
the amendment to house bill 1187 which
and representative bixby did you want a
second
i second that we have a motion and a
second for amendment 03408
representative aaron you're recognized
to speak to your motion
thank you again mr chair
so this amendment basically
adds the section that was accepted
by the senate to a current bill that is
being considered house bill 95
so
it essentially makes this bill the same
and i would just like to add that
while this may seem like a bit of a
technicality or technical procedure uh
that bill is working its way through the
process but we wanted to have this as a
vehicle in case there was some snag that
occurred as that one went through
and that is the reason we're adopting
the exact same language any further
discussion
representative bixby yeah i'd just like
to sort of uh
re-emphasize that and the the original
bill came to this committee and uh hb 95
came to this committee in
last year and we passed it without
difficulty the senate held it up
and uh then they
finally changed a little bit of language
and passed it where we want to make sure
we're basically doing this bill as
insurance
to make sure that the it stays alive
just in case something weird happens
with the the bill that's currently in
the senate but with any luck we'll be uh
acceding to the senate changes at our
next session and sending it to the
governor's desk
thank you
any further discussion
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
the role
on
amendment number 03408 to house bill
representative aaron yes represent
contoir yes
representative johnson yes represent
lang yes represent moffat yes represent
yes represent kennedy
yes represent mason yes representative
sam bowen yes representative bixby yes
represent bolden yes represent dutsy
representative murray yes representative
von polinski
yes represent perez yes mr chair yes
17-0 vote of 17-0 so the committee has
adopted amendment number 03408
i will look to representative aaron for
not to pass his amended motion
thank you mr chair i'd like to move this
uh house bill
with its amendment of zero three four
zero h uh as autop otpa representative
bixby would you like a second second
that
we have a motion of otpa on house bill
1187 with amendment 0340h now recognize
representative aaron to speak to her
motion
thank you
mr chair i think that we have discussed
this and i'd just like to move this
forward
any further
comments from the committee
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
the role on house bill 1187 with amend
representative aaron yes represent
counter yes representative johnson yes
represent blank yes representative
moffett yes
pamula yes representative kennedy yes
representative mason yes representative
sambon yes representative bixby yes
representative bolden yes representative
dutsy
representative murray yes representative
von plinsky representative army yes
representative perez
yes mr chair yes
17-0
the vote of 17-0
house bill 1187 passes otpa in the
objection to putting in on consent
okay next we'll open up house bill 1412.
relative to gardening homesteading and
organic food production and i will look
to representative contour for an ital
motion
mr chair i'd like to itl house bill 14
make a motion to itl hb1412
representative dutsy did you want a
second uh yes i second
all right we have a motion of itl on
house bill 1412 and i'll recognize
representative contoir
to speak to her motion
thank you mr chair
although this bill was well intentioned
there were some issues and based on
testimony our farming laws
and agricultural laws are
already where they need to be and this
would actually weaken them thank you
the chair will further add that i did
speak with the prime sponsor and it was
his request that we itl this bill
any further discussion from the
committee
i'd just like to uh emphasize i i
agree with this uh the
the we had good testimony from the farm
bureau that
better better statutes are already in
place and
the uh
deduction of the
exemption from the state profits tax
would didn't really make sense thank you
representative bixby any further
comments
seeing none i will ask the clerk to call
the role of itl on house bill
1412.
representative aaron
yes
represent contra yes representative
johnson yes represent blang yes
represent moffat
yes represent pamula yes represent
kennedy
yes represent mason yes
represent sam boyne
representative bixby yes
representative bolden yes representative
dutsy
representative murray yes
representative pinsky
representative
yes representative perez yes mr chair
17-0
with a vote of 17 to 0 of itl motion
passes on house bill 1412 and the
objection to going on consent
next we'll bring house bill 1584 fm
establishing a capital improvement grant
program for the benefit of state fairs
and agricultural affairs i'm going to
move ought to pass
and i will look
to uh representative aaron for a second
i would like to second that
i will recognize myself to speak to my
emotion
don't get to do that too often
so um
we've heard a lot of testimony on this
bill from the the prime sponsor and from
the commissioner i think we've had
really good discussion um amongst our
committee on you know the importance of
the fairs and
the importance of the state to show
support for these fairs
so i would ask that the committee
support this motion of ought to pass
while i realized that there may be some
concerns about the distribution of the
funds in
the grant process i believe those
those concerns can be
taken up in
well hopefully ways and means which is
what i'm going to ask the speaker to
send this bill to
and uh
we will
in the rulemaking process if it is
successful in
passing i would ask for your support
i've ought to pass and open it up for
any further uh conversation
anybody have any comments they'd like to
make
representative bixby did you want to uh
yeah i um
i am
i'm kind of on the edge with this bill
but i think that uh if
i'm more comfortable with going to ways
and means as a
way of
examining the
funding mechanism more closely so i am
going to
i'm going to be voting out to pass on
this
yeah although i agree with the intent of
this bill
um i have a difficult time supporting a
bill in which the local communities
which
um reap the economic benefits of a
regional fair are unwilling to put in
any money when we are really really
talking about small
change i mean less than 25 000
and even that is a high
um
you know a high quote and
so i i would not be able to support this
bill even though
i you know do support the idea that
regional and state fairs should
well i guess i'll use uh representative
aaron's mic
okay any further comments from the
committee
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
to call the roll
we are on i've lost my place here house
bill 1584 with an ought to pass motion
and i'll ask the clerk to call the roll
yes
represent mason yes representative
sanborn represent bixby yes
represent bolden yes
represent dutsy no
represent murray yes
represent balmy
yes
represent perez
no
mr chair yes
14-3
with a vote of 14 3 the ought to pass
motion carries on house bill 1584. will
there be a minority report
because the bill has a fiscal note of
250 000 we cannot put it on consent so
with a minority report you can't put it
on because that either
understood
okay our last bill
we're doing very well uh house bill
one two two six fn prohibiting the
declaring of cats and i will look to uh
representative mason for a motion
thank you mr chair i'd like to enter a
motion of entering to the legislature
for house bill 1226 fn
we have a motion of itl do we have a
second from representative perez second
okay we have a motion of itl
uh moved in second and now recognize
representative mason to speak to his
motion
yes thank you mr chair i'd just like to
say that
we heard a lot of testimony on this
and
i understand it's a very controversial
medical procedure
but through the testimony we've also
heard that the veterinarian
of the state of new hampshire have been
moving great strides away from this and
this seems to be policing itself without
having to have legislation to do so it
also
um
criminal
prosecution against veterinarians
when this subject needs this
subject needs to be between the
owners of the pets and the veterinarian
who advises now most of them advise not
to have this operation so
thank you
thank you representative any further
um i represented bixby yes uh
so
uh
i think that uh declawing is definitely
not a good procedure but i think and i'm
particular but i i um
but with this particular bill i'm
particularly disturbed by the uh
criminalization and i think that uh
doesn't that does not make sense uh
and i also
the testimony seemed to indicate that
it's not a very common procedure in new
hampshire and
that
the
veterinary the new hampshire veterinary
medical veterinary association
some confusion between
a correct procedure an incorrect
procedure
leading to criminalization of their
member of veterinarians in the state and
i think those reasons uh sort of add up
to uh not making this particular version
the chair would like to add that i
support all the reasons given for itl
and i think our veterinarians do a very
good job in a very conscientious job of
managing their clients and and
making the right choices and i'm
supporting itl on this bill because i
really don't think it's a new hampshire
problem and i think we're uh
we have again we have a very good group
of veterinaries with veterinarians
within our state that are doing an
excellent job
so seeing no further comments i will ask
the clerk to call the role on house bill
1226 with a motion of itl representative
aaron yes
represent
yes representative johnson yes represent
blang yes represent moffitt yes
represent pamola yes
represent kennedy
yes represent mason yes representative
sam bowen
representative bixby yes representative
bolden yes represent duty
representative murray yes
represent von plinsky
representative almi yes represent perez
yes mr chair yes 16 1. okay with a
motion of 16-1 the vote of 16-1 the
motion of itl passes on house bill
1-2-2-6
is there any objection to putting this
okay
so no objection going on consent
well we did it that's it is all of the
bills that we're going to exact today
so the only other
thing that i want to do is i'm going to
assign
i just have to find my numbers give me
i'm going to assign house bill 1454 to
the solid waste committee
and i'm going to subcommittee excuse me
and i'm going to
assign my kids
i'm trying to find the number on the
second one my apologies i have too many
yeah and i'm going to sign house bill
1186 a companion animal emergency bill
animal protection and licensing
subcommittee
and those
committees will convene next week
2 8 beginning at 10 am
i'll put a calendar notice in on those i
just need to think about how long each
one will need for the each bill so yes
representative murray
could you please remind the members who
are on those subcommittees please i do
not have the list right in front of me
but i i will absolutely do that i'll
send an email to the committee members
we'll make sure that occurs i was
looking for that list too i only have
the subcommittee list not all of the
members
thank you that was my question too okay
i i figured it would be but i couldn't
locate it
yes
oh
okay with that
we uh i want to thank the committee for
your diligent work today um i appreciate
the the ability of this committee to all
work together and pull in the same
direction i understand that times we
don't always have
the same opinions but i certainly
appreciate the uh
the civil discourse that occurs and the
good communication that we have within
the committee so i do thank you all and
i have safe travels home and for those
on the subcommittees we'll see you next
oh i'll remind the committee anyone that
needs to do blurbs please get those in
in the next couple of days to me if you
can
you
it